[Music]
or all of our panelists are under the
impression that there is something
rather than nothing so the question is
why or indeed whether or not we should
ask that question so I'm delighted to
welcome them all to discuss it Rupert
Sheldrake is well known biologist author
of a number of books proponent of the
theory of morphic resonance and a
famously his latest book is called
science and spiritual practices George
Ellis is a very distinguished
theoretical physicist he wrote the book
on the large scale structure of
space-time with Stephen Hawking and Amy
Thomason is a metaphysician and her
latest book is ontology made easy
ontology for those of you don't know is
the the theory of what there is the
theory of existence and Amy is well
known among meta positions for her work
she from University of Dartmouth so very
pleased to welcome them all and we'll
begin with each of them making a kind of
position statement of their view on this
question why is there something rather
than nothing so should we start with you
Rupa oh all right and I was expecting to
go last but we'll shall we start with
Amy that okay by me yes all right so I'm
gonna try to make this question easier
to like I try to make ontology easy so
as the representative philosopher up
here what I think philosophy has to
contribute to a question like this or
most any question is to try to clarify
the question what can it mean what are
we asking anyway and so any good
philosopher starts by defining her terms
right so let's start here with something
and this is a term that I've written
something about in my second book
ordinary objects so something is a
slippery term there's at least a couple
of different uses we have of it in
everyday English there's one use in
which we use it as what philosophers
would call a sortal term roughly to pick
out independently movable unified lumps
of stuff bottles and
it's of paper and so on right this is
the sense in which you say the tables
wobbly can you please give me something
to put under the leg right but then we
also use something that's what I've
called a covering term or some people
talk about a dumb ol dummy sortal and
that is a sense in which from the
application of any other count noun
we're entitled to infer there's
something right so if there's a rock in
my shoe I can say there's something in
my shoe if there's broccoli in the
fridge I can say there's something in
the fridge if there's a protest on Main
Street I can say there's something
happening on Main Street if I'm worrying
about my future I can say there's
something on my mind
but it doesn't have to be a physical
object here right so what are we asking
about when we ask why is there something
rather than nothing maybe we'll talk a
little bit uh thing later I'll start
with something well it can't be the
sortal sense right if we want to know
why there are bottles and tables and
rocks right then presumably physics gave
the answer to us a long time ago we
could explain that in terms of particles
and their ways of unifying and bonding
in certain ways that makes them more
tightly bonded to each other than to the
surrounding stuff that's not what we're
asking about but if we're using the term
in the covering sense then what we
really have to be asking is some more
explicit specific question right but if
we resolve it into some of these other
sortal terms why are there rocks or cats
or cars right then at that stage I think
there's no serious feeling anymore this
is an intractable mysterious question
that the sciences couldn't possibly
answer in fact the most plausible
candidate once you start putting in
substituting in specific terms for
something would be something like why
are there particles right and my
understanding is that as scientists
continue to develop that physicists have
gotten pretty good plausible
explanations of why there are particles
and how these might emerge from quantum
vacuums
right in which case it looks like maybe
we could get a scientific explanation of
that too so as just kind of a brief
introduction to my angle on this I think
we need to refine the question but once
we refine it and I've started by talking
about something that I think what we get
is a series of more scientifically
tractable questions
the apparently intractable old question
that Lydon exposed and Heidegger
reiterated thank you very much that's
very clear thank you George okay I've
got really two things I want to say the
first is about physics and nothingness
and in physics terms many way many
people use it nothing is a vacuum so you
take everything out that you can and you
use the highest pressure thank you pump
you care then you've got nothing no in
fact this because of quantum physics
this is not nothing it's a very very
complex structure and it's now a pretty
well agreed feature of quantum field
theory that when you try to extract
energy all the energy till nothing is
there because of the uncertainty
principle virtual particles are both
buzzing into existence and out of
existence all the time look at the
quantum vacuum is a highly dynamic
structure and there's a huge amount
written about that it exists as it does
because of the underlying physical laws
namely the nature of quantum physics and
so if you say to yourself if you say
could the universe come into existence
out of nothing and your starting point
is this kind of vacuum the response to
this is this is not nothing it's a very
very complex very highly structure why
does it exist because of the nature of
the laws of physics and nothing which
could have a whole defect in terms of
ontology what although there was a
physics wider the laws of physics exist
which is a very complex structure
discussion because there are one view of
the laws of physics that they are
descriptive in another view of the laws
of physics that they are prescriptive
and in neither case do we know why the
laws of physics exist or why they have
the form they have so there's a whole
discussion about that from the physics
side but I want to now complicated the
picture by saying that as someone who is
a physicist but also thinks in more
philosophical terms what exists is not
only physical if you want to say what
exists it is a big mistake to say that
only physical things exist and so what
does any we do not be intimidated by
reductionist into agreeing the
it's only particles and forces that
exist because that isn't true ideas
exist and so alright you may say this
involves the brain and it's a complex
thing so instead let me to say the
following example algorithms exist an
algorithm is a procedure which is used
in computers in order to create things
for instance most of the motor cars that
you drive around and today are created
in factories because an algorithmic
directing what happens in the factory
and that is the reason that the motor
car exists now what is an algorithm made
of is it made of wood or concrete or
particles of some kind the answer is an
algorithm is an abstract entity it is
realized in various ways in these
computers and then through that
realization it causes motorcars to come
into existence because they wouldn't
exist if it wasn't for the album but the
algorithm itself is an abstract entity
so if you want to describe why things
exist not only do you have to think
about why particles exist and forces
because you also gotta think about why
abstract entities exists and I can give
you many other examples with my concrete
immediate example as algorithms which
undoubtedly exist they undoubtedly have
causal power in the real world as it
exists today okay thank you well when I
was thinking about this discussion I
read Lawrence Krauss whose book
something from nothing because that's
the most popular visual version of this
debate from the cosmological point of
view at the moment and what struck me
about it and what struck me about most
arguments is how conservative they are
if you look at traditional discussions
of why there's something rather than
nothing the traditional ones are
theological discussions they start from
the assumption that there's a source of
all things which is threefold in Kashmir
Shaivism it's called para shiva the
unified source of all things with shiva
which represents the principle of form
or order and Shakti which represents the
principle of energy or power in the
Christian version of the Holy Trinity
you have guard the ground of all being
you have the Lagos which is the mind of
God the form the source of all form
and you have the spirit which is the
source of energy movement in power well
in lawrence krauss you have a source
which he doesn't discuss but it has two
manifestations one the laws of nature
which may be the field of all possible
laws of nature that may apply to all
universes but that's taken for granted
as pre-existing and then you have the
quantum vacuum which is the source of
all potential energy and power for this
and all other universes in other words
it's exactly like Shakti and his role of
the laws of nature is exactly like Shiva
or all the law casts on the spirit so
the the this seemingly radical atheistic
view is extraordinarily conservative in
philosophical and theological terms it
just rephrases them and with a few kind
of polemical jabs against sort of
old-fashioned theologians he's basically
restated the ancient case for the
existence of God he goes even further he
says in that the it's the nature of the
quantum vacuum is so unstable that it
almost inevitably would give rise to a
universe through a kind of fluctuation
say okay let's look at Genesis chapter 1
verse 1 the earth was without form at
the world without form and void and the
Spirit of God moved on the face of the
deep all the face of the waters well the
quantum vacuum is pretty well a modern
version of the face of the deep and if
the Spirit of God the wind moves on the
face of the deep it creates waves and
the waves presumably follow a law like
structure so what struck me about all
this was that the debate is essentially
a theological debate that's been
reframed in these modern physical terms
and the really interesting question for
me about it is that in the theological
debate the ground of all this is
conscious where as for Lawrence Krauss
and materialists an atheist the ground
of all this is unconscious no it's a
matter of faith either way I suppose but
as far as I can see the advantage of the
ultimate ground of being being conscious
has first of all you don't you're
there's a basis for these rational laws
instead of the laws of nature being
free-floating mathematical abstractions
that are outside space and time that
apply to all possible universes that are
ultimately metaphysical in the ultimate
sense of metaphysics as being beyond
physics that there you got free-floating
laws which have no ontological basis
whatever and then you have human minds
that appear mysteriously in an
unconscious universe and can actually
understand these laws are though we've
evolved by evolutionary psychology of
sort of using stone tools and primitive
campfire type techniques our minds are
somehow able to comprehend the entire
universe so that there can be someone
like Krauss putting forward theories
about the ultimate nature of reality
well if there's a conscious basis for
both reality and for human minds the
traditional view this makes a lot more
sense take that away and we're left with
a kind of unconscious version of
traditional theology and a lack of
explanation for the existence of minds
of any kind including those of
physicists which in philosophy of mind
is called the hard problem
um it's curious cuz there are lots of
debates which were had in a theological
setting and and now had not in a
theological setting but that doesn't
mean we should think that what we're
debating is the theological debate I
mean it just means that there's a debate
that we were able to articulate in
theological terms we've got a way of
articulating it that it isn't
theological so I don't know what's the
significance of the fact I mean Krauss
has written a popular book about why
there's something rather than nothing I
mean it's kind of unsurprising that he's
going to be echoing old debates about
that topic I mean that's why I wrote the
book and and you know that no no work of
professional physics attempts to ask up
question I mean the reason you ask that
question is you want to sell books to
people it's not really a scientific
project to write a book like that I
don't think I mean it's he claims it is
correct about that and Lawrence Krauss
is one example of a number of my physics
colleagues who are rather confused about
the boundary between physics and
metaphysics
oh there's this debate about whether
nothing is sort of something in virtue
of being nothing or whether it's just
the absence of something and that also
echoes a theological debate about evil
evil on the one hand could be just the
absence of God on the other hand evil
could be a kind of active principle
something substantial so similarly in
debates about nothing we get you know
nothing being really important and
nothing just being no it's just not
something so when I comment on the
nature of nothing sure yeah so I'm
thinking about that too I mean so think
back to what I was saying about
something and now think about nothing so
how do we use the term nothing right and
again in our ordinary business of life
where our terms get their meaning right
well use it as a way of suggesting
there's no things of a particular kind
right the magician says nothing up my
sleeve
pointing out to him that there's air or
skin it's not a contradiction of what
he's saying you might go home and open
the fridge and say there's nothing in
the fridge even if there's some dead
bugs in the corner like he knows nothing
that you would want to eat or prepare
for dinner in the fridge so you might
think you could use nothing to mean the
negation of any sort all but that won't
do for this debate right here's a couple
of really bad answers to the question
wise or something rather than nothing oh
well if there were nothing then it would
be the absence of anything but that's
something right or no because if there
were nothing then there'd be the fact
that there is nothing and that's
something right those clearly aren't
satisfying answers so that shows that
you can't just mean by nothingness the
negation of absolutely any sortal
account now right so what did we have in
mind originally when we asked this
question when somebody like Leibniz
asked this question or when we tend to
worry about it well there's a pretty
plausible case to be made that what we
had in mind is something more like not
why are there abstract entities or facts
or absences but rather why are there
concrete entities the sort of concrete
causal things we interact with right or
that make them up and if that's the case
then again I think we have a plausible
case to be made for thinking that the
root of the question is something like
why are there particles or why is there
matter in which case again I think we
have hopes of getting an answer from
physics although I totally agree with
what George said that any time you give
an answer like that right any kind of at
least standard form of deductive
hypothetical explanation as the
philosopher Karl Hempel called them
right involves you explain why something
by appealing to initial conditions and a
law of nature that explains what you've
observed why did my tomato plant die
because it was outside unprotected and
the temperatures dropped below 32
degrees Fahrenheit right here's a law
that says plants of that sort die in
those conditions therefore it died right
but any kind of explanation we give like
this if that's the form of explanation
you're looking for if you're looking for
something like a causal explanation and
I think the question why is there
something rather than nothing is put
forward as if
looking for something like a causal
explanation akin to why do my tomato
plant die right then you're always going
to have to presuppose initial conditions
and laws then you can always turn the
question back and say why that initial
condition and why those laws and our Y
questions can keep on going but the hope
is that each of them will remain having
the feeling at least of tractability and
approachability in the way that this
totally generic form of the question
doesn't oh yeah so from the physics
viewpoint if there is really nothing
then there's no space there's no
space-time there's no laws of physics
they actually is really nothing and that
is not what physicists have in mind so
but because if the laws of physics don't
exist if space-time doesn't exist you
don't have physics so there's simply the
existence of physics implies that
something exists and this is a problem
for physics because if we now come to
try to explain the origin of the
universe out of nothing we have the
problem that before the universe exists
the laws of physics didn't existence
that we don't have any handle to get on
it in fact it's much worse than that
because if I say before the laws of
physics existed I'm using a phraseology
which assumed that times existed before
the universe exists and that doesn't
even make sense of the phrase before the
universe exists it doesn't even make
sense as a phrase okay but but
nevertheless if you then relating to
Ruppert stuff there are ultimately four
fundamental reasons why something should
exist rather than nothing and the first
is it was inevitable it a'dreea
existence somehow there is some
pre-existing condition which made it
absolutely inevitable now that the
physicists try to create an
inevitability structure through string
theory as a unified theory of all forces
and that funk miserably failed and
created a structure where there isn't
one theory there's a hundred thousand
million theories and the idea to prove
only one physics only one universe could
exist failed the second is the high
probability one to show that what exists
is highly probable now the problem with
that is that
rests in some underlying assumptions
about what is probable and to show that
the universe is what it is because it's
highly probable you have to have a
definition of what is probable and
mechanisms to create probability and
that ends you up in another kind of a
myth the third explanation if you call
it that is that there is no explanation
the universe just is and there is
nothing further to say and that is a
fundamentally logically watertight
explanation nobody likes it because it
doesn't explain anything it doesn't give
you any unification and the final one is
what we were hearing from rupert is that
the universe exists because in some
sense it was meant to be there there is
some purpose in some sense there is some
reason for its existence that takes you
out of physics into metaphysics and that
is again a perfectly logical logical
explanation if you want to explore that
because of the reasons I've said before
existence is not any physics you've got
to look at things beyond physics and the
data that you should take into account
isn't only physical data you should also
take into account data from ethics art
philosophy psychology all of those
subjects as well as data from physics if
you want to explore that as a real
philosophy yes well I quite agree with
that and I think that the I think that
the the data that we have to take into
account include the date the very fact
of consciousness as I mentioned earlier
I mean all of these things algorithms
designs art etcetera products of
consciousness of human consciousness and
there are probably many other kinds in
the universe so then really the question
is I suppose the ultimate question is
does consciousness come first and or
does physical reality come first or do
they both come into being together and
of course we can't ever know the answer
because we couldn't be there at the
moment of the Big Bang or before it to
see the answer so it's speculative and
it's a matter of belief either way what
we have at the moment is a dominant
philosophy within the Natural Sciences a
philosophical materialism which is the
assumption matter comes
and consciousness emerges from matter in
and as yet unexplained way when brains
get big enough a kind of lightbulb of
consciousness goes on but the
consciousness isn't actually anything
it's nothing it's either an Fe
phenomenon or it's an illusion that's
the materialist philosophy of mind so
consciousness itself is problematic it
ought not to exist we ought not to be
conscious it's an embarrassment for
materialism that we are so if we take a
different view if we take consciousness
as primary then we get to a view held by
almost all religious traditions that
there's a consciousness comes first and
gives rise to a universe and this is not
just religious philosophical for Plato
you have a realm of ideas or forms that
comes first the Platonic he calls that
reality and then there's a kind of
emanation or for Neoplatonism and they
kind of emanation from that realm to
give the physical universe so that's
another way of thinking about it now if
it were just a matter of arguing
philosophically that would be the end of
the matter we wouldn't be able to get
anywhere but the reason that religions
exist is because people have had
mystical experiences over the ages where
people through consciousness itself have
felt that their consciousness is linked
to some vastly greater consciousness
than their own which they identify as
the ultimate consciousness of the
universe or God or whatever name they
choose to put to it
and now one could say well it doesn't
count as science but science as Lawrence
Krauss emphasizes is based on empirical
facts and consciousness is the ultimate
empirical fact empirical means based on
experience and consciousness is
experience so the exploration of these
ultimate realities I think involves
mystical experience as well as
scientific measurements of the cosmic
microwave background radiation and
suchlike
and when we take that into account as
well the conscious explanation of
reality then some kind of fundamental
role for consciousness becomes important
and is consciousness of
or is it not a thing I mean that's
another debate which they may have views
on I have used money seems to me that
you you you paint a picture of a kind of
what you call the dominant philosophy of
materialism that makes it absurd I mean
the idea of emergence are quite
straightforward right rocks aren't alive
but when things get complicated you get
life so bacteria are alive spiders are
alive now when things get really
complicated yeah you end up with human
beings that are conscious but before
that you've got all sorts of levels of
perception and sentience and experience
and so on and that's part of the world
but it didn't arise until there was
evolution of life and now how do you
know you present your view as a kind of
common sense view but your your view
really amounts the fact that if every
last human being stopped to exist you
know kind of tables and chairs would
stop existing as well because matter
comes after consciousness but it's
really no no reason to believe that I
mean you're not required to believe that
to recognize that consciousness exists
and also think you overstate the
unanimity and religious traditions I
know I'm chairing our shop um but
there's another religious tradition that
says yeah the explanation for the
material universe is it's create by the
devil he's not created by a nice good
God and because the creation of the
universe by a nice good God doesn't
explain all the hideous things about it
and so there's actually a just as strong
a religious tradition of thinking the
material universe is a corrupt form of
existence that was created by a bad
consciousness not a good one well it's
not there it's yes we had a deus ex
machina oh it's not just as common a
tradition I mean devil worship is a
minority view but Oh both of them but it
also it takes it makes the same point
consciousness cut even if you think
there's a devil creating things
consciousness of the devil comes first
so it puts consciousness first I'm not
necessarily saying consciousness has to
come first and but I am I am saying
consciousness may not be confined to
brains the cerebro centric view of
consciousness seems to me a very limited
one many people have considered
that stars our conscious the Sun may be
conscious Pan psychism is a fashion in
the philosophical world at the moment
where which attributes some level of
mind to many kinds of being so I think
is a huge area of debate so I wanted to
sort of break in here on a couple of
points one is I want to emphasize that
in order to think there's something
wrong with the traditional question one
doesn't have to be narrowly speaking a
materialist I'm not someone who thinks
that only physical material things is I
think abstract entities exist I have
spent a lot of my philosophical career
arguing for and sharing how to make
sense of the existence of abstract
entities like theories and novels and
and so on we can ask why any of those
exists also and then there's a variety
of answers to be given the questions
about why the laws of physics exist or
how to even understand what laws are
rich interesting philosophical questions
why does consciousness exist another
great question and I've written some on
consciousness as well I'm with James on
this one I mean I think we have at least
the beginnings of an understanding that
consciousness emerges from certain
complex forms of life which emerge from
more basic material entities you can
look at other certainly one can look at
other arguments I teach Berkeley every
year right who thought that all of
matter well the idea of matter doesn't
even make sense and that tables and
chairs and the things we see are really
just ideas in the mind of God and then
implanted in our finite minds Barclays
arguments aren't very good I teach them
every year I go through and they're not
persuasive now there's other arguments
out there one has to look at but to me
the argument that goes bottom-up
explaning consciousness by a matter
rather than matter by a consciousness
the cases I've seen of both of these I'm
taking the consciousness by a matter
root as having much more promise of
giving us something deserving the title
of explanation so I don't want to deny
consciousness I don't want to deny
abstract entities what I do want to do
is to sort of clarify and simplify the
question in each of these cases it's
fine to ask questions about how
consciousness comes into existence or
why we should say there are abstract
entities but all of these I think are
much more clear and tracked
and the question simply why is there
something rather than nothing yeah a
brief brief leap in the debate between
you Tom and your side rather than
Rupert's on this mystery except for one
thing I think you said the tables and
chairs didn't require consciousness to
exist yes they no he didn't they were
designed there wouldn't exist to this
they built by human being yeah but don't
stay existing if there wasn't any
consciousness around so in that sense
they don't require consciousness to
exist they require constant to exist
because they've been designed by the
human but they can carry on existing
when there's no consciousness ah that I
agree I agree too I mean I just want to
briefly say in terms of existence and
what exists to me the deep underlying
nature of the cosmos is possibility
spaces now there I could spend a lot of
time talking about that but certain
things are possible certainly not you
can look at the laws of physics in terms
of possibility spaces they allow certain
possibility they don't allow other
possibilities in biology there are
certain things that are possible in
biology and certain things that aren't
and there's a wonderful book about this
by person called Andrea's Varg and
they're called arrival of the fittest
and if you want to see a really
beautiful statement about possibility
spaces and biology read unreal sparked
and the point about these possibility
spaces they are the same now as they
were at the start of the universe they
are independent of the human mind they
control what is possible in the context
of microbiology and if you want to
explain what exists one of the things
you have to do if you want to go deep is
explain why these possibility spaces
exist and then the further level of this
is some of these possibility spaces
relate to thoughts and the existence of
consciousness which then takes you to a
very deep level so my view the deep
level of understanding what exists is
looking at the possibility space is not
just of physics of chemistry and biology
but of mental processes so what I want
to know now is really whether I think I
know what Amy thinks about this probably
it's not worth asking the general
question why is there something rather
than nothing and I think I know what
Rupert things which is something like we
need to ask it in order to realize that
the answer is that God explains but
what's your view about the question do
you think it's a productive question or
one that we shouldn't ask I think as a
physicist as a cosmology she's worked in
cosmology I think it's our duty as a
cosmologist to push back as far as you
can to try to understand as far as you
can and my colleagues are produced all
sorts of we can understand the universe
back to the time we milk our synthesis
back to the time of inflation back and
we then run out of physical theories
because we cannot test the theories we
don't know what the theories are we can
make all sorts of hypotheses about what
the relevant theories are we can think
of string theory loop quantum gravity
all sorts of kind of thing there's no
way we can test them so the ability of
the unit of physicists to predict stops
not at the beginning of the universe it
stops quite a long way this side of the
beginning of the universe and so physics
cannot explain the origin of the
universe because it doesn't relate
toward having forth it can't even
explain what happened for a significant
time after the origin of the universe
so objection to your view might be that
it's satisfying to have an explanation
but it's then once you've got it what
you do then is alright I'm happy now I
know why the universe exists it's God
and know why everything happens God
wants it to happen I never there's
consciousness because God's conscious
and so no need to scientifically
investigate things not more questioning
absolutely I mean this is a caricature
of a belief in God I mean I'm used to
that I happen to believe in God but I'm
used to having my view caricatured so I
don't think it means no more question I
spend my entire life in scientific
research and doing research looking into
things one of the things I'm looking
into at the moment is you know just what
kinds of minds might there be would it
make sense to say the son who's
conscious now an if it is what
difference would it make to the way it
behaves now for someone who believes
consciousness has only emerged from
brains and
stuff then it's not a nonsensical
question but it seems to me a very
interesting one if through another
question if through spiritual
experiences for example exploring the
realm of consciousness through
psychedelics and endeavor which is going
on today on an unprecedented scale not
here no of course no no but it's a there
are people exploring with I mean there's
no we know more about traditional
psychedelics than ever before we know
about synthetic ones there's now a new
wave of psychedelic research going on
showing realms of the mind as realms of
possibility which George was talking
about this possibility space the
ultimate nature of minds is a
possibility space one of the traditional
views of God's mind is is the space of
all possibilities the divine imagination
is the space of all possible thoughts
and imaginations and images and all
possibilities now exploring
consciousness itself is not saying oh
we've got the answer forget about it
that's the end of it it's it's something
that people like Lawrence Krauss aren't
in the slightest interested in because
he thinks he has got the answer I think
that the this taking consciousness to be
primary or at least not necessary
primary I'm not an idealist but taking
consciousness is very important area of
inquiry which consciousness studies are
engaged in at the moment including
taking seriously psychedelic experiences
mystical experiences near-death
experiences and a whole range of other
experiences tells us something about the
nature of minds that we didn't know
before and then it brings up the
question of is this just our mind as my
friend Terence Mckenna said you know the
psychedelic experience is made of mind
but it's not my mind so the I think that
the the idea that this is just putting a
stop to inquiry and is quite wrong I
think that it opens up the whole field
of inquiry and more much more
interesting way than it is opened at the
moment
that you've responded very well to my my
criticism but let me just point out that
loads of the things that you advocate
could be engaged in by someone who is a
materialist I agree I'm not claiming yes
oh good I mean so saying it's another
false dichotomy between no no I mean
Krauss is a popularizer who made a lot
of money saying that he knows where
something comes from nothing but it's
not really very serious intellectually
scientifically project it has a huge
influence he goes on the road implements
that are completely intellectually
shallow yes all right
good but I mean he goes on road shows
with Richard Dawkins the two of them
together claiming to have disprove God
in biology and in cosmology it has a
huge media coverage it influences large
numbers of people and for them because
that's the authority of science Dawkins
was the professor of public
understanding of science Krauss claims
to be you know this enormous of public
intellectual this has an enormous
credibility with a lot of people so
therefore it's worth discussing their
views in a public forum not that we need
to go on with and and I think science
overreach is really dangerous and
because it undermines credible science I
mean it's scientists that I mean someone
said about religion is like a swimming
pool all the noises at the shallow end
and it's like that with lots of things
right and it undermines serious
scientists who wouldn't go out and tell
everyone they know everything the people
who get the airtime are the ones who do
and they thought given misleading
representation of what scientists as
obvious thing because I agree with them
talk to most scientists the main thing
they want to tell you is what they don't
know not what they know the main thing
they want to tell you is the questions
that their their address well I talked
to a lot of them and actually a lot of
them are terribly dogmatic if I won't
talk to them about my research on
telepathy for example the reaction I get
from the majority of scientists is is
impossible and we don't want to know
about the evidence they don't say we
don't know about the mind as so many
things we haven't yet researched about
animal behavior
we're totally open-minded that's not the
reaction most scientists have I'm afraid
I wish you were right
I'm hardly on your side but I do think
we should keep a certain open mind about
issues like telepathy I don't believe it
is possible for what I regard is really
good scientific reasons about my
understanding of how the brain works
nevertheless I think a small amount of
if it should be put into the lepre
theory fits precisely because if it ever
was proved to heaven it would overthrow
so much of what we take for granted as I
I am not anti telepathy research if it
is done properly and you keep out the
charlatans and all the risk but
nevertheless it should be a very very
small budget
well they won't open it's a lot more
than many others would have anyway
that's not really our debate telepathy
but my point is that the consciousness
can be about half the people who work on
parapsychology or materialists of
atheists about half or not and I would
say about the same of people who work on
psychedelic drugs so your point that you
don't require a commitment to one view
or the other to do this research
I completely agree with but what I think
is that it is that the we need an open
mind about these questions about
something rather than nothing or the
nature of consciousness rather than
presupposing a materialistic psychedelic
drugs that there the issue with
psychedelic drugs is that they form a
way of exploring the nature of minds and
consciousness that takes people beyond
their normal consciousness changing
things undoubtedly true because you are
going to find out about the mind but
what people often go a step beyond that
or they say something like I took these
psychedelic drugs I now have this
experience that gave me this insight
into the nature of reality and that's a
different thing all together don't be
some kind of route where I know you know
it's like no one thinks that's plausible
about alcohol do they know really drunk
last night and I really saw the nature
of reality
no but I do understand a lot about the
nature of my mind not through getting
drunk right yes I mean this I see how
fragile my consciousness is and how
easily it can be messed up yes well I
think the point about psychedelics is
that some people have on the makanda
mystical experiences where they feel
they're in contact with the greater
consciousness than their own
some people have mystical experiences
completely spontaneously without taking
any drugs at all
it's what William James called the
noetic experience a feeling of certainty
that one's in contact with something
much greater than oneself no the
counter-argument is over that's just an
illusion like so many other illusions
but for people who have this experience
is very important and it changes their
lives and so for me it's an open
question is this really contacting and
vaster greater consciousness than our
own which is the simplest explanation or
is it some kind of illusion produced by
no new serotonin levels in the brain
which would be a materialists
explanation or is it both I mean it
could involve changes in serotonin
levels it does involve changes in
neurotransmitter levels I would want to
question the idea that the ranking of
which is the simpler explanation here I
mean if you really want to say that the
explanation of it is there's this sort
of universal consciousness that we're
somehow in contact with then you have a
huge range of new questions you're
positing a new kind of being beyond
anything we had understood before at
least if this universal consciousness is
supposed to be something really
important
you've got to explain what this mode of
contact is but it doesn't seem to be
normal perceptual contact whereas the
other kind of explanation that goes
through understanding how our brains
work in the ways in which they can
produce experience as some not all of
which are vertical about the world and
maybe even most of which aren't exactly
the way the world is in itself right
that goes via known routes I mean it
might be complicated but it goes via
unknown paths positing known entities so
I also just want to push back a little
bit I mean I think it is I agree that
it's important to be open-minded and not
to foreclose anything whether in
scientific investigation or follow
sfe but just because we don't know with
certainty that something doesn't exist
that's very different than saying which
we cast our belief there even when we
don't know things for sure we can often
have a pretty good idea and we've got to
rely on this pretty good idea as we
decide what to put our money into for
scientific research what to put our
lives into for investigating and so I
just I often see in public debates this
kind of appeal to oh well we can't know
for sure that this radical view whether
it's a of you about the sort of
universal unconscious or something else
it's false yeah okay but what do we have
some good reason to believe what can
really understand and make sense of and
life is short money is short you've got
to sort of put your effort somewhere
even while remaining open-minded there's
still some Taos to pursue I mean the
other thing one could add is that
there's a middle ground which is you
think well I am getting an important
insight from this kind of experience
which is I'm not very important and my
sense of self is a kind of you know kind
of fallible construct that can easily
dissipate yes and then I'm what am I
left I'm left concluding the world is
much bigger than me and I don't have
that very big important status as an
existing thing well that's true
which Carl Sagan said but that doesn't
say anything about that's true because
I'm in commune with some super Minds
world spirit or something it's just true
that I'm not very important oh yes
I hope it's true we're not and none of
us are but the thing is so these these
experiences for many people are
life-changing and they you know you can
it when as you as Amy said you know you
have to decide where you're going to put
your effort where you're going to put
your money and you know the way that the
vast majority of science funding works
at the moment is business as usual and
that's a very nice note to end on so I'd
like to sincerely thank Oz because I was
taking the debate very seriously even if
I was making jokes I should say of
course it's an important discussion that
we're having and thank you all very much
for contributing to it and
poor people for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you